hey everyone i'm nate from huggingface
and today i'd like to show off our new
keras integration which allows you to
share and reuse any chaos model you've
trained on the hug and face hub
to get started we're just going to
install huggingfacehub in google collab
you can then log into your hug and face
account using the cli
you'll be prompted to provide an api
token with write access so if you don't
already have one here's how you do it
i'll name mine collab and specify that
it has write access because we can be
pushing models up to the hub
we'll just copy that and paste it back
into our collab notebook to authenticate
the keras integration allows you to
share models built with the sequential
api the functional api as well as any
custom keras model
let's start with the sequential api
here we'll build a simple single layer
feed-forward network and build it to
define the computational graph
once you've done that it's only one line
of code to push that up to the hub
we can click this link here and take a
look at the model repo we pushed by
opening it in a new tab
it's up to you to define your model card
by creating and updating a readme.md
file in your repo which is why this one
looks empty
coming back to the notebook we can see
it's just one more line of code to pull
that model back down that we pushed and
reuse it on any machine that we'd like
let's see that we can do the same thing
using the functional api
again we build a simple single layer net
and push it up to the hub
great now if you want to push a custom
keras model you can do so with the keras
model hub mix in
inherit this from this class to add push
and pull functionalities to your model
the only difference this time is that
instead of calling a function and
passing it the model we can simply call
the models push to hub and from
pre-trained methods as they were
inherited from the mix-in
now if these dummy examples weren't
enough for you that's all right i get it
we can do something a little bit more
interesting let's take a denoising
auto-encoder example from the chaos docs
and push that up to the hub for anybody
to try out
we'll speed through this notebook since
it's the same as the one in the docs but
once it's finished we can push up the
hub just as we did previously in just
one line of code
and again we can pull it down in just
one more line of code and see that it's
indeed still cleaning up these images
so that is the hugging face hub keras
integration it's time for you to go out
and try it out the code is available on
github so you can check that out there
and i can't wait to see what kind of
things you're going to share
if you have any questions feel free to
ask in the comments or on our forum you
can also join our discord server to
connect with over 2000 other folks
interested in machine learning thanks
for watching until next time bye